you
hi guys how's it going it's ID is a vice
and fire here and I just wanted to make
this audio recording cuz I'm pretty sure
there's not gonna be much editing in
this video because I just got off of an
editing binge with this dune Messiah
video but I just wanted to talk about
some of the things about dune broadly
and some of the things that I left out
of my dune Messiah video that I feel I
should talk about I just want to say
first off thank you to all the dune fans
that have subscribed to my channel and
like my videos that first ultimate guide
to doing video that I made was a huge
gamble I had never done anything like
that ever before it was a lot of editing
involved and I didn't know if it was
gonna succeed at all because my channel
is about a Song of Ice and Fire well now
it's about A Song of Ice and Fire
and also dune but I grew my audience
based off of a Song of Ice and Fire
and Game of Thrones and you know I spent
months creating that first ultimate
guide to doom video and fun fact and
this sounds silly now
it was initially gonna be one hour long
video about all six new novels and that
was gonna be it that was all I was gonna
do I was gonna do that one big video
about all the doom novels but as I
started to do research I realize I can't
there's no way I started trying to write
a script and I was like this is there's
no way this is gonna be an hour long and
I'm like this is gonna be two hours long
and I thought well I might as well break
it into two videos and eventually it
moved on to like I'll just you I'll do
one part and then I'll do a part for
every book and that was the only way
that it was gone to work and the when I
first put the ultimate guide to do up I
knew it was good I think that was the
best video that I put on my channel up
until that point the ultimate guide to
doom part 1 and I knew it was so good
but then when I uploaded it like I said
I didn't really have like the fan base
that was into it and so the video got
like three thousand views in the first
day and then after that it got about 500
more views over the course of the next
week and a half so me I thought it kind
of failed so I was kind of like a little
bummed out but then all of a sudden it
started to get all these views and I
started to get all these new
subscribers that were really into Doon
and so that really invigorated me so I
went ahead and like kind of got back to
work it made the next video in the
series which was also a massive
undertaking but I'm just really thankful
that the doom fans of the internet found
my channel and that you guys like it
I am NOT a professional at any of this
I'm not a professional video editor I am
NOT a professional voice actor which is
one thing that I really want to stress
to some of you guys because though most
of the reviews and the comments that I
got were phenomenal a lot of you had a
problem with the way I pronounced
certain words and a lot of you were very
vocal and even at times rather odious in
your telling me that I was pronouncing
certain words wrong but I took I took
the criticisms and I attempted to
improve my pronunciation of certain
words like quiz that's had Iraq because
you know I read the books and when you
when you're reading something you tend
to think about it in a certain way and
you think about it in a way in your head
that's really not when you say it out
loud you're not saying it right but I
don't think it was that huge of a deal
and some of you got angry with me and
that's a little shocking because I'm
like I spent a lot of time working on
these videos literally weeks putting
together these videos and it's like kind
of disheartening like just because I'm
mispronouncing a word or not pronouncing
it in the way that you would like that
you're so angry about it see I don't
really think there's a big deal
in saying Leto rather than Leto or alia
rather than Leah but that's neither here
nor there and I will continue to attempt
to improve my pronunciations where I
deem necessary but I make these videos
because I really do love doom I really
really do love doom and I made a risk
like uploading doom videos to my channel
I didn't know if anybody was gonna watch
these videos or care about these videos
it just so happens that people did but I
did it because I think Doom is important
especially now I'm a big fan of comic
book reel 19 and I watched her dune Club
and at the time she was doing her dune
Club I was planning to make my ultimate
guide to doom series but I watched her
doom Club and she has a lot of if you
haven't seen it
should go watch those videos as well but
yeah dune is very important it's very
socially relevant there's a lot of ideas
in doing that we can apply it to today's
society
I mean dune talks about social
engineering governmental systems society
in general religion philosophy all sorts
of different ideas are in these novels
and I think it's very important to
explore them because Frank Herbert was a
very very smart guy and I'm even I I
honestly think I can comfortably say
confidently say that he is a genius or
that he was a genius see the thing about
talking about dune also if you're
talking about it well you're probably
gonna piss some people off because it
deals with things like religion first of
all which is a big one in dune Messiah
like I said in that video I think Frank
Herbert is not only criticizing religion
he's creating he's criticizing the
societies that lead to the rise of
messianic figures and you saw in the
begin you saw in the beginning of the
dune Messiah video Frank Herbert himself
speaking and he mentions the Jim Jones
cult and I don't know how many of you
know about the Jim Jones cult but
basically back several decades ago in
the United States there was a man named
Jim Jim Jones who used religion as a way
to trap people and it started with
Christianity but once he got them in he
basically convinced these people not to
worship Jesus but to worship Him and the
point is they're already open to
worshipping someone in the first place
so he became their messianic figure and
eventually these people moved to I think
it was South America and in the end they
all ended up committing suicide because
they they went off they bought this plot
of land and we're talking 900 people
these are hundreds of people a mass
suicide well it was a murder-suicide
obviously but there were children there
as well and the children were murdered
obviously in people that didn't want to
take the poison because there were a few
defectors that were like no and these
people weren't literally forced by the
other people and I've actually gone
through because I'm a morbid person and
I've listened to the audio recording of
when this mass suicide happened and you
can hear these people cheering for their
own
deaths he's saying we're gonna drink the
sign out and they're like yeah let's
drink this cyanide
let's poison ourselves because we
believe in this figure so much we
believe in this Messiah so much dune
let's kill 61 billion people let's
spread a jihad throughout the universe
because we believe our way of thinking
is so right
we believe in Paul Muad'Dib so much that
we will we will kill 60 billion people
including men women women and children
for Paul Muad'Dib we will kill in his
name because we believe it so much that
is what Frank Herbert is criticizing
Paul did exactly what Jim Jones did he
went in and he twisted the myths and
legends that were already in place in
Freeman Society you know just like Jim
Jones did to Christianity he twisted it
and he built his own religion where he
was the center of it he was a messianic
figure
and these people followed him blindly
but what you also see is the crumbling
that happens when this occurs well
specifically when you mix religion and
in government if you recall Jessica's
letter you produce a deadly paradox she
says and what she means is when you mix
religion and government you create a
system that is inherently unstable it
cannot survive it will necessarily fall
that is what Jessica meant by her letter
and if you look at the ending of doom
Messiah the hero loses Paul loses his
powers he's blind walks off into the
desert he's completely demystified and
you see this again in god emperor of
dune and i think that's one of the big
points of this entire thing don't mix
religion and government do not do it in
our own society at this very moment even
if you are religious right and I'm and
I'm not trying to talk down on anybody
that's religious but even if you are you
have to see that mixing religion and
government is a problem you have to see
that because I'm gonna i'm just using
christianity as an example but you look
at a book like the Bible
you open the Old Testament and you see
thou shalt not suffer a witch to live
you know many women were killed over
that line
but then but then a Christian would say
the New Testament negates all those old
laws but then another Christian would
say well what about the Ten Commandments
and then another Christian would say or
another person would say what about
Jesus saying on the sermon amount that
not a jot or tittle of the law will be
changed so it has all these
contradictions and so when you try and
take something like this with all these
different interpretations that can be
had try and make it law you're gonna
create an unstable system and you're
gonna crash that system it will fail and
it will fall and you're just gonna
create a hostile Society for everyone
it's gonna be a horrible society for
everyone so we can't do that like a
government must be secular and that's
what Jessica is trying to say you can't
do this you cannot mix the two they
don't go together right so moving on
from that a little bit I also want to
talk about Aliyah right so in a way
Aliyah Atreides is kind of the main
character of this story she's maturing
into a woman and really it's in this
book that you really start to see the
weight of her other memories of her
ancestral memories it starts it just
starts to press on her in this novel and
you will see more of this in Children of
Dune when in this novel you see the
beginning of this Aliyah is a terribly
tragic character she didn't have a
choice in any of it and then the fact
that Jessica left her here Jessica like
flew off to Khalid and left her only
daughter here and you will see like that
that come up again in children of doing
as well because that also affected
Aliyah being abandoned by her mother and
yeah like I said I think she's a
terribly tragic character completely
trapped in snared by Paul's vision she's
completely trapped by it and she's as
anybody would be she's completely
frustrated by it she's totally
frustrated by it she wants to be able to
see as Paul sees and she almost dies at
the end of the book in an attempt to do
so Paul
himself is a dictator Paul is a tyrant
he is not the hero and that that's
another point of do Messiah it's to show
you that Paul is no hero yeah he
triumphantly new overthrew the Emperor
but then what happens after that 61
billion people die like the Freeman
Coulter is all but destroyed so that's
that's part of the reason that the
Freeman that there's like a little bit
of backlash against him because the
Freeman culture is being worn down and
destroyed and some of them are rejecting
this new way of life and that's the the
point behind the Freeman conspiracy
element of this what I also find
interesting about doing Messiah is that
you hear throughout doing that Paul is
fearful of this jihad and you're kind of
anticipating it but then you get to do
in Messiah and it's like it's like oh
that already happened it skips right
over it he skip spread out he skips
right over all of it
so I've listened to Frank Herbert's
speak in an interview and it says that
he ended dune in a way that was kind of
anticlimactic like he built the action
building building building and it just
stops and you skid right out of the
story and it's like you Skid so far
that's your skid right past the jihad
and then you get this new version of
Paul that's brooding and tyrannical and
just not not the same character from
book one at all really so the key point
of doom really is don't simply follow
someone just because they're charismatic
don't blindly follow anyone always think
for yourself think critically and think
rationally and also I think that's
something that's missing from our
society today I remember growing up in
school like we do like an int that we do
like we'd get like these booklets right
and like every chapter there'd be like
one little section at the end that'd be
like think critically and it that one
little section but the rest of it's just
like fill in the blank fill in the blank
fill in the blank there should be an
emphasis on how to think critically in
in schools I think because people really
don't know how to do that people don't
know people don't understand how to go
about having a rational discourse and I
think in the United States where I live
really we really have just
problem with education in general right
because I remember learning about the
scientific method for instance in school
but I never really got the weight of
what it actually the significance of the
scientific method until later on in my
life when I actually made an effort to
like learn things for myself because it
was just I guess the school that I was
at it was just not sufficient but that's
neither here nor there and what you
realize is that science rational thought
that is the single most accurate way
that we have of determining reality
right I think people tend to look at
science it's just another belief system
or something like that but that's not
what science is I am a science is just a
set of rules a set of steps that we have
for discerning the nature of reality
that's what science is it's a system
that we use to understand what's true
and what's not all right and it's
extremely accurate
I mean people trust science when it
comes to oh you have a heart condition
and we need to operate but people don't
trust science when it comes to yeah the
Arctic just rose 45 degrees and there's
no ice and it's in the it's supposed to
be Arctic winter the hello global
warming and people like oh no it's
propaganda so you don't trust science
when it comes to that but you'll trust
science in every other facet of your
life every person that's listening to
this right now like you you your life is
great because of science right all of
our lives will be much worse without
science vaccines computers easy access
to food easy access to water these are
all virtues of science you know this
this all came from rationality so I
really wish more people would apply
rational thought and critical thinking
to just everything in their lives right
I really think you should and when
someone tells you something don't just
simply believe it because you like this
person or you think this person is an
authority don't even listen to what I'm
saying like look look it up do research
for yourself you know one of the reasons
that I chose to make doing videos was
because I would always tell people to
read the books read them but you know
you tell someone to read something
not gonna reheat it especially something
like dune you might read that you'll
read the first page and be like whoa
this is too much for me not doing that
and I've had people react that way when
I said hey you should read this so I
said you know when it's gonna be just
saying this I should just create a video
that tells people what it's all about
and see if I can get people interested
and I'm so so very happy that so many
people have come to me and said that
they've bought the dune books because of
me or that they've started reading them
because I mean because I think that's
important reading in general is
important I know cliche but it really
really is but doing in particular I
think is very important so the next big
video that idea will obviously be
children of tune which is the third book
in the series dealing with Paul's
children Leto and ghanima and then also
princess Irulan is there and also you
get to see how alia is as a ruler so you
really get to it the Leah's story really
expands in Children of Dune and then of
course God Emperor which takes place
fifteen hundred years after Children of
Dune and God Emperor is absolutely my
favorite it's number four my favorite
book in the entire series and you know
it's crazy a bunch of doom fans haven't
even read God Emperor with you and a
bunch of people stopped after children
of doing which is that mistake oh my god
do not do that because God improved oon
will blow your freakin mind God approve
doing is just it is amazing I love that
novel I really do and it's not like any
other novel that you've ever read you
cannot compare Frank Herbert's got
improv doomed to anything else
alright so I think I'm about ready to
wrap this up I got one more point people
ask me all the time about the Kevin J
Anderson books and the Brian Herbert
books they extended universe books to
the Dune series I have read some of them
I have met I have not read all of them I
know a lot of you out there hate them
obviously they're they're not the same
as Frank Herbert's books obviously
they're not they don't have the same
depth that Frank Herbert's book books
have but they're enjoyable for what they
are and maybe some time in the future I
will perhaps do the ultimate guide to
Brian Herbert doom but maybe maybe not I
don't know but I have started to talk
about
them a little bit in my little sections
where I cover specific topics but yeah
thank you guys for watching and I
appreciated like and subscribe if you
haven't already consider supporting me
on patreon if you like my Doon Compton
or if you like my song advice is very
common because like also dune fans if
you're not into a Song of Ice and Fire
please get into it you know I know Game
of Thrones is like super hyped up and
you might have seen the show and thought
oh it's not really that great but those
books George Martin is another genius
and I've talked about him you can check
out some of my videos on a Song of Ice
and Fire and you'll see what I'm talking
about George Martin is another one of
those people that put that puts all the
stuff there's all the socially relevant
stuff about people and the way they
interact with each other and governments
and just oh just it's great and then
Jordan Martin is a person that has such
a deep understanding of just history
he's a history buff so like the things
that are happening in A Song of Ice and
Fire
they relate to what's happened they're
very similar to what's happened in our
own history so yeah check it out and
it's similar in a way that Frank her but
does it like heat both of them are
talking about cycles cycles the same
stuff happens over and over and over
again where there's 20,000 years in the
future or whether it's in Westeros it
happens over and over again and I think
both Frank Herbert and George or Martin
get this so yeah here's the real ending
things a little awkward but thank you
guys for watching peace out ideas of Ice
and Fire
you